[Música]
ele vem vindo em minha direção
mete medo porque ele é bombadão é
daqueles que só pensam em pegar mulher
cheio de isso ó fica doido se acabam aí
pede o meu mas eu já tomei mali grita
tanto que eu fico longe
i toda hora pergunta se eu vou acabar eu
digo que acabei de começar
ele quer rezar mas nunca nunca a cabo
exercícios pensa que é o dono do supino
o pdk no meu é de metal eu levo tudo sou
o animal é como supinos agachado monstro
oi já já está me olhando mais do que o
normal
tachando esquisito e me sentindo mal eu
quero saber o que é que tu tá vendo os
teus cão âmbito e sim é tombada em baixa
aos cambito o braço é doce a pena só os
gravetos
quem nasce de longe parece um cometa
só os campi os outros gigantes apenas só
os cambitos respeito início apenas só os
cambitos seu corpo tá em cima depois
para little eu quero
é quanto falhando no hotel shopping no
reto inclinado on 0
favorito o que importa é praxe feito que
fica bonito vir a quebrar chegou chegou
o dia das perdas ocorre quando tu fica
me olhando
ou seja tudo pensando ou eu tô até manhã
do ano me deixado eu jamais é pena mas
nunca tinta e até o mali pequeno porque
aparece não está cara super cool
arrecadação nem a vontade mas com o
campo cheio apenas pela casa
a select pass eu acho que eu fui ler a
dia mas já um short tem que ter coragem
também tocam gritou mas nesse âmbito que
eles vão crescendo porque tokito já não
quebra tem que toda na cabeça quando
aparece apenas de uma merda cambista o
camb toalhas cambito que eles vão
crescendo porque tô ki tô já não quebra
tem que ter dali cabeça papel aparece a
perna de uma beleza o els camby e simon
bateu só os cambitos o brasil é que o
sistema só os gavetões vem na city longe
parece correcto
só os camby os ombros 17 apenas só os
cambitos respeito isso apenas aos câmbio
topo tá em cima de vós palitot
eu quero dizer
é ponto valeu do teu sofrer um retweet
na dom joão jacinto favor o que importa
é praxe feito que fica bonito
[Música]
eu acho chegou chegou no dia da china eu
pago os cã em cima da lombada em baixa
sós bonito brasileiros as pernas só pra
vetou a venda se longe parece um boné e
doa cambito cambito mas esses também tu
eles vão crescendo porque tá sobre o
rosto inclina dom
eu já assisti os favoritos
também do camb toalhas bonito que eles
vão crescendo por vitor conflito que
nunca tem que ter bélica vezes bacana
parecia a pena de uma mesa onde deus
cambito e aí ela assistiu canal eu sou
ídolo nissan fugiram levando o estado
ele aqui é o bombado que não lhes
cambito se você gostou dessa paródia
seja fazer aqui no youtube clicando em
gostei lá no facebook você vai curtir a
publicação não esquece kurt e vai marcar
seus amigos que esquece de manaus
cambito esse é o canal
o tirulipa pra você clicar na cara dele
e direto pro canal dele se inscrever ou
pode ser o primeiro link da inscrição
que também clicou se inscrever no canal
tirulipa tamo junto
não esquece gostei e essa foto que foi
postada está ganhando vai falar no
instagram dele aonde limpa e curte a
foto que aparece no instagram na boca
notou é nóis é essa aqui a foto que eu
postei no instagram
e aí você vai lá nesta foto no arroubo e
nunes e curtir lá e comenta
só os cambito embaixo tamo junto é nós
valeu